bonsoir Le 7 8 politique sur TVfil 78
dernier édition pour cette saison dans
un instant Christophe Boissonnade
première adjoint au maire de voisin le
Bretonneux il est délégué du Parti
radical nous parlerons avec lui de
l'avenir de cette formation après
l'arrivée de Laurent Hénard à sa tête
pour succéder à Jean-Louis Borlo et puis
ensuite avec Valérie Pécresse nous
reviendrons sur cette année électorale
le bilan après les européennes et les
municipales et surtout comment l'UMP
envisage l'avenir mais tout d'abord nous
sommes en ligne avec Christine Boutin
conseillère générale des Yvelines
candidate aux européennes sous
l'étiquette force vive bonsoir Christine
Boutin bonsoir et merci d'être en ligne
avec pour le 7 8 politique avec nous ce
soir je voudrais tout d'abord vous faire
réagir sur ce qui s'est passé lors du
concert du groupe Indochine au Stade de
France samedi dernier une image de vous
a été diffusée juste avant un morceau du
groupe contre l'homophobie 80 000
spectateurs du Stade de France qui vous
ont sifflé comment vous avez réagi
lorsque vous avez appris ça
naturellement
valorisation d'utiliser mon image le
plus grave c'est qu'ils ont passé avec
mon image de parole que je n'ai
absolument jamais dites et que je ne
peux pas envisager de dire mais enfin
bon très très violente à l'égard des
personnes homosexuelles qui avaient été
prononcées lors d'une manifestation avec
Civitas
que ce n'était pas vrai
justement
que là vous allez déposer plainte contre
le groupe il y aura une suite judiciaire
ou pas
d'Indochine j'aime bien leur musique
c'est vrai que leurs paroles sont
parfois un peu douteuses mais bon j'aime
bien leur musique voilà donc j'étais
absolument ahurie de ça et je trouve
qu'il y a aussi une incitation à la
violence qu'il me semble un petit peu
déplacé dans les temps que nous vivons
actuellement en tous les cas ce qui est
certain c'est que je n'ai jamais jamais
dit les paroles qui ont été mis sur mon
image et naturellement en justice
on en revient à la politique 1,14% des
voix c'est votre score en Île-de-France
avec le label force vie cela signifie
pas de remboursement de campagne et vous
avez appelé d'ailleurs vos sympathisants
au don est-ce que finalement vous êtes
rentré dans les frais de cette campagne
pour laquelle vous aviez engagé beaucoup
d'argent personnel
c'est vrai que bon le score était
souvent j'espèrerai je ne me faisais pas
d'illusion c'est une femme politique
expérimenté et je voulais à l'occasion
de ces élections dire vraiment les
valeurs que nous portons et qui sont
importants pour nous donc j'espérais
bien sûr faire les 3% pour être
remboursés aujourd'hui vous manque
combien pour pour bouclerc
encore 50000 euros cela veut dire que
force vie va avoir du mal à perdurer
quel avenir pour force vie aujourd'hui
renforce vite continuera d'une façon
d'une autre vous savez ce qui est assez
extraordinaire c'est que les 151
personnes qui se sont engagées en France
sur les listes de force vie nous avons
tous eu un score à peu près semblable
elles sont toutes décidées à continuer
elles sont toutes heureuses d'avoir
porté ses valeurs elles ont le sentiment
du d'avoir fait et il faut continuer et
on soutiendra d'autres voilà mais nous
avons tout à fait l'inconscient de
poursuivre à lisser laisser passer et
puis on proposera des choses à la
rentrée et en ce qui concerne votre
engagement personnel vous allez vous
présenter à d'autres élections je
rappelle puisqu'on envoyait quelques
images que vous êtes aussi conseillère
générale des Yvelines
et que c'est on verra
il semble que le mandat de conseil
général a été encore prolongé d'un an
donc continuons le combat de conseil
général et puis pour les aux élections
on verra vous savez maintenant je suis
plutôt dans le dans la posture du
soutien du Conseil grâce à mon
expérience politique je pense que je
peux apporter aux jeunes mon expérience
et c'est ça ce qui motive merci
Christine Boutin d'avoir été en ligne ce
soir pour chaque politique merci à vous
faire si je reçois à présent Christophe
Boissonnat bonsoir vous êtes le premier
le premier adjoint d'Alexandra Rosetti
et la mère de Voisins-le-Bretonneux et
les goût également délégué du Parti
radical dans les Yvelines pour débuter
une réaction à l'actualité du jour c'est
la garde à vue de Nicolas Sarkozy qui a
été mis en cause dans une affaire de
trafic d'influence présumé un ancien
président en accusation de cette manière
cette inédit forcément lorsqu'on
s'intéresse lorsqu'on s'engage en
politique on a forcément un avis sur
cette question là effectivement c'est
très regrettable pour le pour l'image de
la politique en général
après voilà si s'il y a eu des
malversations il est normal que tout
homme politique même un ex-président de
la République doit vous rendre des
comptes après je ne me permettrai pas de
commenter
les éventuelles décisions de justice
appartient uniquement effectivement au
juge après Jean-Luc Borlo aujourd'hui
c'est Laurent Hénard qui est à la tête
du Parti radical de votre partie le
maire de Nancy a été élu par les
militants assez largement face à amayade
61% vous acceptez ce résultat vous qui
avez soutenu à Mayade effectivement j'ai
soutenu à Mayade parce que pour moi
c'était la meilleure candidate en termes
de jeunesse de renouveau du Parti
radical et puis surtout de notoriété
quand on cherche à développer un parti
ce qui est important c'est d'avoir un
président très connu les français pour
pour attirer un maximum d'adhérents le
scrutin ce que je regrette en tant que
militant effectivement c'est que le
scrutin se soit pas déroulé dans des
conditions optimales on a été très
sévère sur ce même sur l'issue du
résultat sa campagne donc à Laurent
Hénard est entachée de graves
irrégularités qui méritent des
vérifications approfondées
ça dépendra des dépendra des
investigations il faut voir si
effectivement c'est ces irrégularités
sont avérées
aujourd'hui Laurent et le président du
Parti radical et que ce soit au niveau
national ou
départementale nous sommes unis et en
tant que radicaux tous solidaires au
sein de la même famille donc aujourd'hui
tous derrière un seul homme celui qui a
été désigné même s'il y a des
investigations en cours et encore des
enquêtes
en France que ce soit pour Monsieur
Sarkozy monsieur Edward monsieur Hénin
ou n'importe qui il y a quand même enfin
je fais pas de comparaison il y a quand
même la présomption d'innocence tant que
les les choses qui sont approchées sont
pas avérées il y a pas de raison de
douter de sa bonne foi en tant
qu'adhérent partir radical aujourd'hui
vous n'avez pas peur que ça crée quand
même des tensions vous nous dites tout
va bien on échange entre nous au niveau
des différents adhérents ça il y a pas
eu de cassure
alors au niveau national c'est vrai que
les cassures sont quand même un peu plus
même beaucoup plus virulentes qu'au
niveau départemental il y en a pas au
niveau départemental enfin du moins je
parle des Yvelines nous sommes tous
derrière notre président enrichard au
niveau national ça va être un peu plus
de temps effectivement à se réparer et
ça peut avoir une incidence sur l'UDI
aussi parce que le Parti radical c'est
un élément fondateur de l'UDI Jean-Luc
borloquet qui a quitté le parti radical
qui a quitté l'udaï pour des raisons de
santé c'est pour ça qu'il y a ces
nouvelles élections là il va y avoir
forcément une nouvelle élection aussi à
l'UDI ça va avoir une incidence ce
scrutin qui s'est pas forcément très
bien passé au parcours je crois pas
franchement parce que les radicaux ont
vraiment
l'intelligence collective de
d'outrepasser leur leur différence et je
pense que au sein du deal Parti radical
étant la colonne vertébrale de l'UDI le
parti le plus important et puis pour
reprendre
les paroles d'un ami c'est
le Parti du Centre voilà le centre de
l'Union exactement
il y aura pas de souci il y aura pas de
conséquences pour lui dire de femmes
pour incarner ses partis politiques
partir radicale udi également mais
derrière tout ça les idées parce que
tout à l'heure en introduction vous
disiez je soutiens à Mayade parce
qu'elle incarnait aussi le renouveau
elle incarnait la jeunesse c'est pas
forcément le cas de l'ENA adresser de
critique à son égard mais quelles idées
vous voulez défendre vous avec le Parti
radical un parti radical c'est c'est la
République les valeurs républicaines
avec un r majuscule on est le plus vieux
parti de France et paradoxalement le
plus méconnu donc c'est juste un peu
regrettable c'est pour ça qu'il est il
est important qu'il notoriété importante
au niveau de la présidence du parti
radical pour développer nos idées auprès
de la population française
c'est aussi bien évidemment la laïcité
qui aujourd'hui est souvent remise en
cause sont les radicaux qui en 1905 ont
fait voter la voix sur la loi sur la
laïcité donc voilà ce sont des grandes
idées comme ça évidemment l'humanisme
nous défendons aussi des valeurs
européennes voilà ce sont vraiment les
grandes lignes directrices aujourd'hui
les aujourd'hui ça fait 100 ans qu'on
existe quand même donc depuis longtemps
du Parti radical c'est une directrice
que vous ne voulez pas changer
ancien et avoir des idées neuves alors
au-delà de ça le rapprochement avec le
Modem ça faisait partie des discussions
avant les campagnes européennes quel
avenir avec le modèle quel avenir au
centre partira l'UDA modem voire même
UMP parce que certains aimeraient se
rapprocher de l'UMP c'est pas forcément
le cas de tout le monde à l'UMP qui
aimerait aussi que l'UMP se réactive
comment vous voyez-vous l'évolution de
votre formation le Parti radical va
rester sur sa ligne directrice comme je
vous le disais après effectivement c'est
un allié historique et naturel puisque
nous sommes au centre droit donc un
allié naturel de l'UMP pour le modem
nous avons prouvé que une entente était
possible pour les européennes avec
l'alternative
bon maintenant il faudrait aussi que le
en ce qui concerne le modem les
positionnements soient claires pendant
les municipales on a eu des alliances à
droite des alliances à gauche en ce qui
concerne le modèle on nous sommes centre
droit nous l'affirmons et donc voilà par
rapport à certaines alliances il faudra
préciser certaines choses municipales
des européennes aujourd'hui dans les
Yvelines que représentent le Parti
radical le Parti radical alors on n'a
pas les chiffres puisque on s'est
présenté sous la bannière
udi en termes d'adhérence peut-être en
terme d'adhérence c'est très
confidentiel c'est une ça veut dire que
c'est très peu c'est une centaine
d'adhérence sur le sur les Yvelines
c'est un parti qu'on redéploie qu'on
redéveloppe on a tout un travail de qui
a été fait déjà et accompli par le sous
la présidence d'un nom Richard pour
remonter le nombre d'adhérents dans les
Yvelines et aussi créer la section udi
de
Versailles et de des Yvelines en général
donc voilà c'est un travail de fond et
je pense je compte sur le le dynamisme
de ramaya de pour mettre au profit du
parti sa notoriété et continuer
continuer dans cette voie là même si
elle n'a pas été élue président du parti
de toute façon elle le sera elle l'a dit
elle-même au-delà de ça il y a un homme
aussi qui est au-dessus de tout ça c'est
Jean-Louis Borlo qui a présidé partir
radicale qui a présidé l'UDI il faut une
place encore pour lui on sait que niveau
santé il va mieux il regarde ce qui se
passe aussi dans cette formation
politique vous aimeriez qu'il revienne
d'une manière ou d'une autre s'impliquer
je crois que on le souhaite tous oui
effectivement c'est c'est un grand
monsieur et il l'a laissé une certaine
voilà un certain vide suite après son
départ que ce soit au sein du Parti
radical ou à l'UDI bon les dirigeants du
Parti radical continueront sur la lignée
de Jean-Louis Borloo il y a ça ne fait
aucun doute après c'est vrai que c'est
quelqu'un qui qui nous manque juste
humainement quoi pour le Parti radical
l'été sera calme maintenant que la
campagne est passée oui alors on a un
congrès samedi le 113e
et après effectivement je pense que ce
sera le temps du repos et après on
travaillera sur les nouveaux dossiers
dès la rentrée le chantier de la rentrée
la présidence de l'UDI peut-être aussi
alors effectivement le congrès de l'UDI
aura lieu au mois d'octobre donc ça va
être aussi un gros chantier nous aurons
l'occasion bien sûr d'en reparler dans
ce 7 8 politique qui reviendra dès le
mois de septembre merci Christophe
boisson
première adjoint à la mer de voisin le
bretonneu merci encore à vous nous
poursuivons cette émission avec le
rendez-vous proposé par l'UMP dans les
Yvelines samedi la responsable
départementale de l'UMP Valérie Pécresse
a voulu fédérer ces militants lors d'un
déjeuner champêtre et pour l'occasion
François Fillon s'est déplacé ainsi que
quelques instants après lui les deux
hommes ne se sont pas croisés Bruno Le
Maire à l'ancien Premier ministre
correspondable du parti depuis la
démission de Jean-François Copé n'a pas
donné d'interview à la presse et l'année
au moins voulu réaffirmer son ambition
de se positionner en recours recours
face au gouvernement et recours face à
la crise traversée par son parti pour
l'écoute
il nous manque juste deux choses
un petit peu de liberté
en particulier pour tous ceux qui
travaillent et un petit peu plus
d'autorité de l'État pour faire
respecter la sécurité et la justice sans
laquelle la devise de la République
n'est plus qu'un slogan vide de sens
alors c'est vrai peut-être que le
Premier ministre le nouveau Premier
ministre est plein de bonnes volonté
mais il ne pourra pas enrayer la chute
il est trop tard il est face à une
majorité divisée il est face à des
syndicats qui sont amères et qui sont
crispés il est face surtout à des
corporatismes qui sont maintenant après
deux ans d'échec et d'absence d'autorité
du gouvernement
exacerber quand un gouvernement en
France recule une fois il est raillé il
est moqué
quant à gouvernement recule deux fois
les Français l'achèvent et bien c'est
exactement la situation dans laquelle se
trouve aujourd'hui ce gouvernement et
cette majorité à l'occasion de se
déplacement de François Fillon et de
Bruno Le Maire nous avons rencontré
Valérie Pécresse Anthony Rech lui a
demandé de dresser le bilan de cette
année politique dans les Yvelines
notamment dont elle a la responsabilité
entre municipales et européenne il a
aussi forcément été question de l'avenir
de cette formation l'UMP
bonjour vous réunissez les militants
aujourd'hui pour ce déjeuner champêtre
l'objectif c'est d'essayer de renouer le
dialogue aujourd'hui oui bien entendu
beaucoup de militants m'ont dit leurs
colères leur écoeurement face à toutes
les révélations tout ce qu'ils entendent
dire sur l'UMP et je crois que c'était
un moment très important de se retrouver
aujourd'hui pour parler à la fois
d'unité de probité et puis en même temps
de comment reconquérir le coeur des
Français par des propositions fortes des
réformes du renouvellement aussi des
personnes donc je crois que c'était un
moment important et d'ailleurs il ne
doit plus y avoir de dire des chefs à
l'UMP et moi je ferai tout c'est pour ça
aussi qu'aujourd'hui j'ai tenu esquier
et Bruno Lemaire et François Fillon
c'est pour ça qu'en septembre nos
inviterons tous les candidats qui seront
candidats au congrès à venir voir les
militants je veux plus de guerre des
chefs je veux qu'on montre le visage
d'un parti politique serein un parti
politique qui se réunira le jour venu
derrière son chef incontesté celui qui
sortira du Congrès et je crois que cette
nécessité de rassembler elle est
indispensable et elle est évidemment en
plus indispensable pour moi qui veut
construire l'alternance en Île-de-France
justement rassemblement et pas implosion
possible c'est vraiment le maître mot
rassemblement vous savez l'UMP est
toujours en danger et elle est en danger
parce que les affaires ça suscite les
curemans de tous nos électeurs et que
les cœurs membres peut accompagner le
désamour et donc le désengagement donc
je crois qu'il faut vraiment qu'on
répète à tous nos électeurs à tous nos
militants il y a des personnes très
honnêtes à l'UMP des personnes très
idéalistes qui veulent changer votre vie
qui font de la politique pour vous et
pas pour elle et de ce point de vue il
faut toute une exemplarité de
comportement là qu'il y a quelques
semaines nous avons eu la question des
logements sociaux à la région
Île-de-France moi je considère qu'un
conseiller régional ne doit pas
s'attribuer se faire attribuer par sa
collectivité un logement social parce
qu'il donne le sentiment qui se sert
alors qu'il est pas là pour se servir en
premier il est là pour servir
ces électeurs c'est c'est l'administré
comme on dit donc je crois
qu'aujourd'hui nous devons travailler à
l'exemplarité de tous les partis vous
parliez de la région Île-de-France on
sait que évidemment vous allez faire
cette campagne comment ça se passe
justement tout doucement là où vous
commencez à aller sur le terrain à voir
les Franciliens bah vous savez que le
gouvernement a décidé de reporter les
élections d'accélérer une réforme
totalement improvisée pour pouvoir
surtout reporter les élections et donc
reporter une défaite annoncée et bien
c'est pas grave moi de toutes les façons
je ne suis pas pressée la seule chose
qui m'inquiète c'est le retard que nous
prenons en matière de logement avec la
loi du flow en matière de transport avec
les crédits du Grand Paris qui ne sont
pas là en matière d'apprentissage moins
11% pour les le nombre d'apprentis dans
toute l'Île-de-France cette année sur
les lycées les budgets des lycées sont
complètement en baisse sur les internats
ils sont pas construits donc cette
région elle a besoin d'une alternance
elle a besoin d'une énergie c'est la
première région de la cinquième
puissance mondiale donc il faut la
réveiller il faut en faire quelque chose
tout le monde l'a quitte parce que vous
êtes rendu compte les jeunes s'en vont
pour voir parce que l'herbe est plus
verte les familles s'en vont parce que
la vie est plus douce ailleurs et
maintenant les retraités sont bons parce
que la retraite coûte moins cher
ailleurs alors je vais vous dire si on
continue comme ça l'Île-de-France va
décliner et moi je veux la sauver je
veux la redresser malgré les dernières
crises internes à l'UMP les résultats
des élections étaient bons dans les
Yvelines pour pour le parti puisque vous
avez conquis des bastions notamment la
communauté d'agglomération de 50 ans en
Yvelines ça c'est un point énormément
positif oui je crois et je l'ai dit à
plusieurs reprises je crois qu'il y a
une UMP d'en bas qui est née dans ces
municipales et moi j'ai vraiment
œuvré pour la faire naître j'ai
travaillé avec beaucoup de de jeunes de
la jeune génération dans tous les
départements notamment en Île-de-France
dans le Val-de-Marne dans l'Essonne dans
les Yvelines dans le Val-d'Oise en
Seine-Saint-Denis en Seine-et-Marne pour
que apparaissent des nouvelles équipes
et que ces équipes et bien gagnent la
confiance des habitants et c'est vrai
qu'on a remporté des villes personne n'y
croyait à part moi confiance à Honorine
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines mais même pas
les eaux un peu plus loin de chez nous
Juvisy là il est rose donc je suis
Clamart donc je suis vraiment très
heureuse et je suis très contente aussi
que les nouveaux maires reviennent pour
pour me dire à quel point ils sont
heureux de porter des idées de la droite
et du centre sur le terrain alors cette
génération terrain c'est avec elle qu'il
faut construire et c'est elle qui porte
le nouveau visage de la droite c'est
pour ça que d'ailleurs je vais parrainer
une association qu'ils ont décidé de
créer qui s'appellera les nouveaux
visages de l'Île-de-France et qui
réunira les mers les adjoints les
conseillers municipaux de ces nouvelles
équipes mais aussi les leaders
d'opposition dans les villes que
malheureusement on n'a pas encore réussi
à conquérir et justement sur ces villes
que vous n'avez pas encore réussi à
conquérir est-ce que vous vous êtes
inquiète de du monde de la montée du
Front national par exemple sur certaines
villes des Yvelines ou d'autres c'est
vrai que le Front national prospère
quand l'UMP est défaillante et on le
voit très clairement dans les Yvelines
dès que on n'arrive pas à se mettre tous
derrière un candidat unique se divise ou
dès que on met pas toute notre énergie à
défendre nos couleurs et bien le front
vient j'allais dire marcher sur nos
plats de bandes vient prendre toute la
place donc il faut si on veut combattre
le Front national être totalement
intègre être totalement unie et être
totalement j'allais dire à l'initiative
dans le domaine concret de ce qu'on peut
faire pour changer la vie des Français
dernière question j'imagine que l'été va
être actif et agité pour l'UMP il va y
avoir plein de choses qui vont se mettre
en route ecoutez moi mon été il est
simple immersion auprès des Franciliens
qui ne partent pas en vacances pour
parler avec eux de leur vie de leurs
difficultés de tout ce qu'on pourrait
faire pour eux vous voyez moi je ferai
de la vraie politique de terrain avec
justement tous ces élus de terrain qui
m'accueilleront
merci de nous avoir suivis tout au long
de l'année pour le 7 8 politique année
politique très chargé le 7 8 politique
revient au mois de septembre n'oubliez
pas que les autres magazines et le
journal se poursuivront sur notre
antenne jusqu'au 11 juillet et puis bien
sûr sur le site internet pour voir
toutes les éditions et tous les
reportages à bientôt